(audience cheering)
- So I was talking to
Brian before we got here.
Y'all know each other.
You've known each other for like years.
- For years and years.
- Many many.
- And Robin, Brian's wife,
is one of my best friends
since she was a bridesmaid at our wedding
and we were at their wedding.
- Yeah.
- And that's like over 30 years.
- That's lik a long time ago.
- A long time ago.
- That's like for us it's almost 35.
And for you...
- 34 then, yeah
- Yeah, exactly, just one year apart.
- Oh my gosh, so wait, do y'all,
have y'all ever had like,
I mean in that time I'm...
- I haven't seen him since.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I imagine you've
had a game night or dinner
or some kind of fun thing
y'all done together, right?
- Well, we've had many fun
things that we've done together.
But there is a really fun
thing that we've done.
And sometimes we have
a dinner at our party,
at our house called Sing
for Your Supper Party.
And we tell people that they have to come
and they have to sing.
And you don't have to be a singer.
You can be anything in the
business, but you have to come,
you have to bring a song
or you get no dinner and...
- What do you mean you
don't have to be a singer?
So they don't have to sing?
- No, like if...
- Well they have to sing.
Let's say, they have to sing.
But you don't have to be
a professional to do it.
As a matter of fact
it's better if you're not a professional.
- Oh my God, this is like my
best friend's wedding when
Cameron Diaz does the karaoke.
- It totally dislike that.
- But you know, my pianist
comes and he can play anything
and people just show up with their songs.
And there've been many times
that people really impress you.
- Oh my God.
- In more ways than one.
(laughing)
- They dive deep or
and they really commit.
- Exactly.
- Those are the people
I want the dinner party
the ones to really commit.
- Yes.
- Well Brian's goal
was to do new things in 2023.
And that was actually around here.
- Right.
- Because I feel like we don't
actually visit where
we're living, you know
we don't see like the tourist stuff.
- No.
- What, do you have
any goals for 2023?
- I have no goals.
- I love it.
(laughing)
- Zero goals.
You know why?
I've tried to keep a journal.
- Oh.
- And I can never get
past the eight week mark.
And I've had like all sorts of journals.
Like little journals, big
journals, journals with pen,
the five year journal where
all you have to do is write
like two sentences a day.
- I fail at that too.
- I can't even do that.
- Yeah.
- I've done video journals.
Can't do it.
(laughing)
- Yeah, well if you need
help with video journals,
he has expertise in that
with great expectations.
- Oh I can do it.
- Yes.
- Yes, that's true.
- He actually could interview
and help you out in this area.
- I think I might have to ask Brian.
- Yes, y'all should do that
at your next dinner party.
- Exactly.
- And I want the film
for the show next time you're here.
- For sure, for sure.
- So wait, your film a Man called Otto?
- Yes.
- I love this.
It stars is your husband.
So it's getting great reviews.
- Who's her husband?
- Yeah, who is that guy?
- Congratulations, no one knows him.
- I know met him.
- We've never heard of him.
Tom Hanks, so, no it's
getting great reviews
and it's incredible.
So you've always wanted to do
all this kinda stuff, right?
- I've been producing for a while.
- Yeah.
- And I did the
My Big Fat Greek wedding
movies, the Mama Mia movies.
- I totally just yeah, totally...
- And I love it and this
was based on a Swedish book
called A Man called
Ova and a Swedish film.
- Yeah.
- And I saw it
and I thought it was
just a beautiful story
and took us a while, but
we got the rights to it
and it's out right now in theaters.
I'm so happy.
- That's so cool.
(audience cheering)
That was a clip from A Man Called Otto
which Rita produced along
with her husband Tom Hanks.
Rita also wrote a song for the film.
- Yes.
- And I heard that
it was just shortlisted for an Oscar.
- It was.
- That's that's incredible!
(audience cheering)
That's incredible.
- Thank you.
- How did that come about?
Like how did, how did the song come about?
- Well, the song is called Till Your Home.
- Okay.
- And it is written
with David Hodges.
- Yeah.
- And sung with Sebastian Yatra,
who's an amazing Latin artist.
- Yeah.
- And it came about
because the director
Mark Forster was familiar
with my music and my albums and he said,
I think you should write
a song for the movie.
And I was like, the songwriter
in me was so thrilled.
I was doing like interior cartwheels.
- Yeah.
- And then the producer of me,
in me was saying, oh my
gosh, what if he hates it?
I'd have to fire myself.
- Yeah, this might get awkward.
- Yeah exactly, might get awkward.
But fortunately that didn't happen.
And yeah, the song is is
out now, Till You're Home.
- I love that, congratulations.
- Thank you, Kelly.
- That's incredible.
- Thank you, you're such
an amazing song writer.
- That's incredible though.
Like to write something and
it be a part of something else
that you're, that's a
really cool, I love that.
- It's very, it's very humbling
and very satisfying and
it feels really good.
- Your different worlds
are coming together.
- The different worlds are coming together
and you know, as a songwriter too
to me it's one of the
most satisfying things.
- Yeah.
- It's their part of me
that I feel like I can use my metaphorical
and literal voice at the same time.
- Yeah, and you can get away with saying
it's metaphorically speaking
but it's really literal.
- It's really literal exactly like...
- And you just say, yeah,
just what if you were
in this relationship?
- Yeah, exactly, what if?
Like actors do.
- I don't know but like
someone out there might know.
- Yes, exactly.
- So Brian, have you ever
done any of songwriting?
You have so many other jobs and
things you're great at, so..
- Well, as a matter of fact
(laughing)
when I was on Malcolm in the Middle,
I used to...
(audience cheering)
- My audience is in love with y'all.
- I used to, my character
used to hum and whistle a lot.
- Oh yes.
(whistling)
- And then I got a call from
the music supervisor at Fox
saying, are you a member of BMI or ASCAP?
And I said, no, why?
And he goes, well, because I need to write
down every second of music on a show
and you're whistling and humming.
- That's true.
- Unless you're whistling
and humming someone else's work,
And I went, how dare you.
(laughing)
- This is my original.
- Original.
And so to this day I will get a cheque,
it said, Hal humming, two seconds.
Hal whistling second and a half.
- Oh my gosh.
- So it got to a point
where I was collecting
these little cheques
and I would cash them
and buy drinks for all the crew.
- Oh that's so great.
- Oh I love that.
- And sometimes a crew
member would come by and say,
hey Brian, it looks
like a good opportunity
for Hal to whistle on his way to the car.
And I go, you just want
a drink, don't you?
- Got it.
(laughing)
- All right...
- We know where
that money's gonna go.
- You should do an album
called Whistle While You Work
and just have it be your whistling songs.
- Exactly.
(audience cheering)
- That's the producer.
- I could of used...
- But I have watched her sing
in so many different places.
I saw her open for
Chicago, the band Chicago.
- Oh my gosh.
- You were fantastic.
In 54 Below, I've seen you.
- That's right.
- And in other places
and you're marvelous.
- Thank you Brain.
I mean, you really are.
You're not just a friend.
- Thank you my buddy.
I paid him to say that
- No, it's so cool though, like I said,
when the world's collide
as well and you get to do,
well, I feel like I get to do it here.
I get to do the show, but I
still get to involve music.
- Exactly, exactly.
- It's nice when that happens.
It breaks up the monotony.
It's hilarious you just said whistling,
I'm like, Jocko is actually
whistling on my new album
that's coming out and he's
actually the beginning
of a whole song with his whistle.
(whistling)
I just was thinking that
when you were whistling.
I was like, that's hysterical.
- There he goes.
- That's literally opening up
my album, Possibly.
But anyway, your your new album
is called Rita Wilson
Now and Forever Duets.
- Yes.
- So it's heavily inspired
by the seventies.
- Yes.
It's all cover songs from the seventies.
And sort of re-envisioned as
conversations and duets, right?
Because I was thinking,
what if these songs were
actually conversations that people were,
lovers were having with each other.
- Yeah.
- So I get to sing
with amazing people like Smokey Robinson,
Willie Nelson, Keith
Urban, Leslie Odom Jr.
- Gosh Groban, that's a lot of people.
I mean yeah, Elvis Costello.
- Yeah.
- So it's very...
- What's it like asking, like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like when you ask, like I get nervous.
- Nerve wrecking.
- Yeah 'cause
it doesn't matter, like
how how many award,
whatever you do, you're
still very nervous about like
or you could just say, no,
it's a dumb idea, right?
I don't know (mumbles).
I like literally preface it.
- Exactly, like I give
them the out right away.
Like, I mean, maybe you
would wanna do this seriously
but it's okay if you don't want to.
As a matter of fact I'm
hanging up right now,
because what's the point?
- I just don't wanna hear the no,
but I know that I might hear a no.
But in this case, very
lucky, very, very humbled
by everybody who was able to show up.
- That's awesome.
- It's really great.
My co-producer Matt Rawlings
is an amazing producer
and he had worked with Willie Nelson
on Willie Nelson's Gershen
and Sinatra albums.
And so Willie was the
first person to say yes.
And we did Slip Sliding Away together,
Paul Simon's song and
very, very beautiful.
- Did you hang out on his bus?
(laughing)
Because I have, and I didn't partake
and yet still walked out feeling fine.
- Contact high, contact high.
No, I did not hang out on his bus,
but this year he sent
me hemp tea and coffee.
That he's got his own hemp tea and coffee.
He and his wife Annie
sent that for Christmas.
- You know, he's a connoisseur,
so I would trust his product.
- Yeah, it's good for the muscles.
- Yeah it is.
(laughing)